toss a coin to your Witcher because
geralt is getting a next gen makeover
before the end of the year The Witcher 3
wild hunts Next Gen update will launch
on December 14th CD projekt Red has
announced the upgrade arrives as a part
of The Witcher 3 wild Hunt complete
edition for Xbox series accent s
PlayStation 5 and PC CD project red is
promising a quote plethora of
enhancements such as Ray tracing faster
loading times and new content based on
The Witcher Netflix series more details
on the new content included in the
complete edition will be announced
during a live stream next week the
complete edition includes the base game
all DLC and the two major expansions
hearts of stone and blood and wine at
launch the complete edition will be
digital only but a physical version is
coming later for anyone who already owns
The Witcher 3 wild Hunt on PS4 Xbox One
and PC they can get the next gen
upgrades for free the PS4 and Xbox one
versions of The Witcher 3 wild Hunt are
also welcoming quote numerous
improvements and the Netflix content but
not until later on The Witcher 3 was
Game of the Year at the 2015 game awards
which this year's nominees have just
been announced unsurprisingly the 2020
pack is led by heavyweight Blockbusters
God of War Ragnarok 10 nominations while
Elden ring and Horizon forbidden West
have seven nominations each in a big
surprise stray has the third largest
number of nominations for a single game
with this Indie title having earned six
nominations in total overall Sony has
games with a combined total of 20
nominations and opponent interactive and
Nintendo's share second place with 11
nominations each and Bandai namco's
Games have an impressive eight
nominations across the 30 award
categories the game awards will once
again be hosted by Jeff Keeley and like
previous shows it will feature more than
just the titular Awards the event has
become a showcase the game reveals with
each award category usually bookended by
new games making their debut and updates
on highly anticipated titles before
their release the return of Crash
Bandicoot has been teased for the 2022
game awards and the show launched its
own Discord server ahead of the main
event nominees for Game of the Year
include a plague tale Requiem Elden ring
God of War Ragnarok Horizon forbidden
West stray and Xenoblade Chronicles 3.
for the full list of nominees across all
categories head to the link in the
description ahead of Wednesday's Warzone
2.0 launch Activision has released new
information about the free-to-play
release confirming a leak from before
Warzone 2.0 was even announced players
will be able to interrogate downed
enemies to acquire Intel such as the
locations of their allies or equipment
like C4 they've placed loadouts can no
longer be purchased from a buy station
players will either have to wait for
them to drop sometime between the second
and sixth Circle collapses or clear out
a PVE stronghold replacing loadouts in
the buy stations is the custom primary
weapon from your Loadout for more info
on all the new updates to Warzone 2.0
head to gamespot.com what do you think
of this year's Game of the Year nominees
are you going to be checking out Warzone
2.0 AT launch this Wednesday let us know
in the comments below and we'll see you
next time for more Gamespot news
[Music]
thank you